a disastrous establishment groupthink
has emerged around the extreme version
of dr filiz plan
I think widespread testing and contact
tracing is going to be absolutely
essential to finding out exactly where
we are in this and this fight against
this deadly virus the variables will
include the capacity of the healthcare
system to identify isolate and treat
those infected so they can slow the
spread we can't open the country back up
until we can do testing on a massive
scale why aren't we even close it will
be impossible health experts believe to
fully reopen the country short of the
vaccine which still seems a year or so
away unless there's widespread testing
just in the last few days the
establishment put up a new road block to
reopening tripling the number of tests
to quote identify the majority of people
who are infected and isolate them from
people who are healthy this
establishment groupthink is
miss-information it ignores the latest
data no surprise that big business has
bought into it too Jeff Bezos told
Amazon shareholders this week that those
who test positive could be quarantined
and cared for everyone who test negative
could re-enter the economy with
confidence what an idiotic statement
we've got enough problems without Jeff
Bezos casually throwing out ignorant
unscientific mumbo-jumbo but this is how
some state and local leaders are talking
to Gavin Newsom this week said the
California will need the widespread
ability to test contact rates and
isolate before relaxing it stay at home
order Los Angeles Mayor Eric Garcetti
said the same thing these people and
their public health officials talked to
doctor foul Chi now I'd like to talk to
dr. pouchy his advice is hugely
consequential unfortunately although
we've been asking for a while he won't
talk to us
so tonight I'm just gonna ask the
questions anyway and see if we get a
reply one dr. pouchy you keep telling us
you're led by the science and the data
why was your data so wrong for so long
why didn't you Commission survey testing
like the Stanford team have just carried
out to get an accurate picture of the
spread and fatality of this
iris will you carry out nationwide
survey testing immediately - based on
this new data do you now accept that
it's unnecessary and impractical to
identify isolate and contact race
everyone who has this virus 3 will you
tell the governor's the media the big
business bosses like Bezos that
widespread virus testing of individuals
is not necessary for reopening will you
rule out immunity certificates
immediately for do you agree that all
deaths matter not just coronavirus
deaths will you commit to a study of the
long term public health costs of the
shut down to help inform any future
pandemic response and factors like
disrupted medical treatment suicides
rise in opioid and other addictions and
lower life expectancy caused by shutdown
induced poverty